hello everyone welcome to part four in
our series on supervised sentiment
analysis this is the second screencast
in the series that is focused on a data
set for sentiment and that data set is
dynacent uh this video could be
considered an optional element in the
series i'm offering it for two reasons
really first uh this is a new data set
that i helped produce and i would love
it if people worked on it it would be
great to see some new models new
insights
all of that would help push this project
forward in interesting ways the second
reason is more practical i think that
this data set could be useful to you as
you work on the assignment and the
associated bake off you could use the
data set itself for supplementary
training data you could use it to
evaluate your system and as you'll see
there are a few points of conceptual
connection between this data set and the
brand new dev and test sets of
restaurant sentences that are part of
the bake off this year
so let's dive in here's a project
overview first all the data code and
models are available on github at this
link
um this data set itself consists of
about 122 000 sentences
they are across two rounds and i'm going
to cover what each round means
and each of the sentences has five gold
labels in addition to an inferred
majority label where there is one and
i'll return to that as well i think
that's an interesting aspect to this
kind of data collection
the associated paper is possible 2020
which i encourage you to read if you
want to learn even more about this data
set and how in particular it relates to
the stanford sentiment tree bank our
other core data set
and another ingredient here as you'll
see when we get to round two is that
this is partly an effort in
model in the loop adversarial data set
creation for round two crowd workers
interacted with a model attempting to
fool it and thereby creating sentences
that are really difficult and are going
to challenge our models in what we hope
are exciting and productive ways
so here's a complete project overview
let me walk through it quickly and then
we'll dive into the details we begin
with what we've called model zero which
is a roberta model that's fine tuned on
a bunch of very large sentiment
benchmark data sets
the primary utility of model zero is
that we're going to use it as a device
to find challenging naturally occurring
sentences out in a large corpus
and then we human validate those to get
actual labels for them the result of
that process is what we hope uh is a
really challenging round one data set of
naturally occurring sentences that are
hard for a very good sentiment model
like model zero
on that basis we then train a model one
which is similar to model zero but now
extended with that round one training
data so we hope that in bringing in that
new data and combining it with the
sentiment benchmarks we get an even
stronger model
that is the model that crowd workers
interacted with on the dynabench
platform to try to create examples that
are adversarial with respect to model
one so they ought to be really difficult
we feed those through exactly the same
human validation pipeline and that gives
us our second round of data
so two rounds of data that can be
thought of as separate problems or merge
together into a larger data set i think
we're kind of still deciding how best to
conceptualize these various data assets
so let's look at round one in a little
more detail this is where we begin with
model 0 and try to harvest interesting
naturally occurring sentences
we so the rod model 0 is a roberta-based
classifier and its training data
are from customer reviews which is small
the imdb data set which i linked to in
an earlier screencast sst3 which you saw
in the previous screencast and then
these two very large external benchmarks
of product and service reviews from yelp
at amazon you can see that they're very
big indeed
and the performance of model zero on the
data sets these are our three external
data sets it's pretty good they're range
from the low 70s for sst three to the
high 70s for yelp and amazon so this is
a solid model and i will say
impressionistically if you download
model 0 and play around with it you will
find that it is a very good sentiment
model indeed
so we use model 0 to harvest what we
hope are challenging sentences and for
this we use the yelp academic data set
which is a very large collection about 8
million reviews and our heuristic is
that we're going to favor in our
sampling process harvesting sentences
where the review was one star
so it's very low and model 0 predicted
positive for a given sentence and
conversely where the review is 5 stars
and model 0 predicted negative
we are hoping that that at least creates
a bias for sentences that are very
challenging for model 0 where it's
actually making a wrong prediction we're
not going to depend on that assumption
because we'll have a validation step but
we're hoping that this is a kind of as
adversarial as we can be without
actually having labels to begin
this is a picture of the validation
interface you can see that um there were
some examples given in a little bit of
training about how to use the labels and
then fundamentally what crowd workers
did is they were prompted for a sentence
and they made one of four choices
positive negative no sentiment which is
our notion of neutral and mixed
sentiment which is indicating a sentence
that has a balance of positive and
negative sentiments expressed in it i
think that's an important category to
single out we're not going to try to
model those sentences but we certainly
want crowd workers to register that kind
of mixing of emotions
where it appears
so here's the resulting data set and
because we got five gold labels for
every sentence there are two
perspectives that you can take the first
one i've called distributional train and
this is where essentially we take each
one of the examples and reproduce it
five times for each of the labels that
it got so if an individual sentence got
three positive labels
two negative then we would have five
examples three labeled positive and
three labeled negative with the actual
text of the example repeated five times
what that is doing is essentially
simulating having a distribution over
the labels and for many classifier
models that is literally the same as
training on the distribution of the
labels as given by our crowd workers i
think this is an exciting way to bring
in uncertainty
and capture the fact that there might be
kind of inherent disagreement among the
crowd workers that we want our model to
at least grapple with
and in the paper as we discuss these
this gives better models than training
on just the majority labels but you can
take a more traditional view so majority
label here means that at least three of
the five workers chose that label uh
that gives you 94 or 95 000 sentences
per train and then these devon test sets
have 3 600 examples each and presumably
we would predict just the majority label
for them
what's more open is how we train these
systems
and in the end what we found is that 47
of these examples are adversarial with
respect to model 0.
and as you'll see the dev and test set
are designed so that model 0 performs a
chance on them
yeah that's some model zero versus the
human so here's a summary of the
performance i showed you these
categories before and i'm just signaling
that we have by design ensure that model
zero performs chance on round zero
we could compare that to our human
baseline for this we kind of synthesized
five annotators and did pairwise f1
scoring for them to get an estimate of
human performance that is on the same
scale as what we've got from model 0 up
here and we put that estimate at 88
for the dev and test sets i think that's
a good conservative number i think if
you got close to it that would be a
signal that we had kind of saturated
this round and would like to think about
additional data set creation i do want
to signal though that i think this is a
conservative estimate of how humans do
and one indicator of that is that
actually 614
of the roughly 1200 people who worked on
this task for validation never disagreed
with the majority label which sort of
starts to suggest that there are humans
who are performing perfectly at this
task putting this at a pretty low bound
and here are some example sentences
these are fully randomly sampled with
the only bias being that i set a length
restriction so that the slide would be
manageable these are the same examples
that appear in the paper where we needed
to fit them all into a pretty small
table i think this is illuminating
though so it's showing all the different
ways that model 0 could get confused
with respect to the majority response
and i would like to highlight for you
that there is a real discrepancy here on
the neutral category what we find is
that because model zero was trained on
large external benchmarks its notion of
neutral actually mixes together things
that are mixed sentiment
and things that are highly uncertain
about the sentiment that it's expressed
for whatever reason so you get a lot of
borderline cases and a lot of cases
where humans are kind of inherently
having a hard time agreeing about what
the fixed sentiment label would be
i think that dynasty is doing a better
job of capturing some notion of neutral
in these labels over here then we should
be a little wary of treating three-star
reviews and things like that as a true
proxy for neutrality
um
this is a good point to signal that the
validation and test sets
for the bake off of the restaurant
sentences were validated in the same way
as dinosaurs so those sentences will
have the same kind of neutrality
that dynacent has which could be opposed
to the sense of neutrality that you get
from the stanford sentiment tree bank
which was of course underlyingly kind of
gathered in the setting of having a
fixed five-star rating scale
so that's round one that's all naturally
occurring sentences let's turn to round
two so recall that we benefit from round
one at this point by training a brand
new model on all those external data
sets plus the round one data set and
then we have workers on dynabench
interact with this model to try to fool
it when we validate the resulting
sentences to get our round two data set
so model one is again a roberta based
classifier what we've done for our
training here is more or less carry over
what we did for the first round except
we have up-sampled the sst to give it
more weight and we have dramatically
up-sampled the distributional labels
from our round one data set effectively
trying to give it equal weight as all of
these other data sets combined in the
training procedure so we're trying to
get a model that
as a priority does really well on our
round one data set
here's a look at the performance of this
model
and first i would just note that it's
doing well on round one right about 81
which is well below humans but certainly
much better than the chance performance
by design that we set up for model zero
i do want to signal though that we have
a kind of drop in performance for a few
of these categories you can see that
especially for yelp and amazon where
model 0 was at about for example 80 here
model one dropped down to 73 and it's a
similar picture for dev and more or less
that's repeated for amazon with a drop
from about 76 to 73
and 77 to 73 similarly so we have a
trade-off in performance that i believe
traces to the fact that we are
performing some changes to the
underlying semantics of the labels
but that's something to keep in mind and
you can see that there's a tension here
as we try to do well at our data set
versus continuing to do well on these
fixed external benchmarks
here's the dynabench interface and
there's one thing that i want to note
about it this is the stock interface but
we've actually concentrated on a
condition that we called the prompt
condition where workers instead of
having to just write a sentence as a
blank slate you know sit down to an
empty buffer and try to fool the model
they were given an inspirational prompt
which was in a tested sentence from the
yelp academic data set and invited to
modify that sentence if they chose in
order to achieve their goal of fooling
the model in a particular way and this
proved to be vastly more productive it
led to more diverse and realistic
sentences i think we'd essentially freed
the crowd workers from the creative
burden of having each time to come up
with a completely new sentence and we're
hoping that this procedure leads to
fewer artifacts more diversity and more
realism for this adversarial data set
collection procedure
our validation pipeline was exactly the
same as round one and here is the
resulting data set it's a little bit
smaller because this kind of adversarial
data set collection is hard and you can
see how good model one is it was
actually pretty hard for crowd workers
to fool this model they did so only
about 19 of the time
uh here's the data set for
distributional training you have about
93 000 sentences and if you go for the
majority label training you have about
19 000 and the devon test sets are
smaller but again the reason they're
smaller is that they are designed to set
model one as having chance performance
on this data set
and so that's what i'll flesh out here
you can see that this model chance
performance i showed you before that
it's doing pretty well on round one and
we had that kind of tension with the
external benchmarks in terms of human
performance we're at about 90 using that
procedure of synthesized kind of
averaged f1 values and i would just note
again that that's certainly conservative
in that you know almost half of the
workers never disagreed with the
majority label so it is certainly within
the capacity of individual humans to
perform essentially perfectly on this
data set
but 90 is nonetheless a good signpost
for us as we think about hill climbing
and launching subsequent rounds of
dynacent
and here are some short examples and i
think they make the same point that our
neutral category is more aligned with
the semantics of what we mean when we
identify neutral sentences and less
heterogeneous than you get from
naturally occurring
neutral sentences derived from star
rating metadata and so forth so i'm
hopeful that this is a kind of positive
step toward getting true ternary
sentiment but we should be aware that
this label shift has happened in these
data sets
and the final thing i want to say is
just to reiterate that if people do
exciting work with this data set and
start to make real progress on the
existing rounds that would be our cue to
launch new rounds the dyna in dynacent
is that we would like to have an
evolving benchmark not one that's static
but rather responsive to progress that's
made in the field and the evolving needs
of people who are trying to develop
practical sentiment analysis systems so
do let us know what kind of progress you
make and what you discover